yeah i'm gonna put this [ __ ] on
so see you're so pretty tom
it'll make the review a lot
that's better faster see it's wind swept
oh okay yeah there you go it works it
works i'm blind
well no i was gonna see if you were
gonna make some kind of like thing that
would relate it to
uh the movie that we were talking about
today yeah death race
2000 yes the dystopian
sci-fi action comedy i guess from 1975.
it's like a satire
really yeah well yeah but it's kind of
supposed to be ridiculous
they're they're um it's supposed to be
yeah they're kind of um
poking fun at the american professional
sports industry
you know probably nfl mostly where
america's addiction to like violence
little did they know that it got even
more violent as time went on
[Laughter]
they were complaining about something
that had not reached full
fruition you know that's true yeah now
[ __ ] video games if a video game's
not violent then if
[ __ ] won't sell right yeah but he's
like uh we know we don't want that but
at least it's like fake stuff
right well the thing about death race
2000 uh this came out in 1975 if i
didn't mention it it was produced by
roger corman yeah so you know the mark
of quality
and uh direction for him it was actually
this is one that a lot of people
remember
yeah and it was directed by paul bartel
who actually had done
he did the original little shop of
horrors um i think he wrote bucket of
blood like a bunch of other roger corman
movies and i think he did lust in the
dust
yeah with divine and tab hunter so uh
yeah
stallone was in it yes in a very early
role yeah
was this his post porn role wasn't he in
a porn movie called italian stallion
yeah yeah this might have been after
that yeah it was after that i think
yeah and then um it also had the guy who
played the bad guy from
um from um
karate kid yep guy who ran the dojo he's
in it
yeah david carradine is in it david
carradine is kind of the main character
yeah
frankenstein yeah and uh it's just a
[ __ ]
wacky mary warrenov is in it she was in
like a [ __ ] ton of movies i didn't
recognize any of the women she was in uh
she was also in shopping mall she's been
in like a [ __ ] ton of things
she was in a [ __ ] ton of movies it's
kind of like a movie about
america's a dystopian kind of
totalitarian
country where it's ruled from afar by a
bunch of corporations and a president
who
is kind of like a god-like being who's
up on top of a damn mountain
and it's pretty good like a pyramid or
whatever the [ __ ] that one
people people basically have to stay at
home i think
uh that is a lot of it right where they
don't have to do anything they can just
kind of live
i don't think well i don't know they
don't go too much into it because i mean
like i said this is like a really cheap
like roger gorman movie so it's not like
they had a lot of money to do
world building or anything well they had
it was something having to do where they
had traded something or other for
prosperity
yeah i guess so well i mean it's
jingoism and stuff
yeah because it's like an authoritarian
type of uh
kind of [ __ ] going on yeah the flag is
just red and silver now
it's the same well i thought it was like
isn't it like a fist with like a
lightning bolt or some [ __ ]
yeah that's where the stars would be in
the in the blue background yeah yeah but
the rest of it is just it's red and
silver instead of red white and blue
um each car has each car in the race has
its own theme
and you're supposed to race across
country and
uh i guess you have to be the first one
to cross the finish line
and also you're getting points for
running people over
yeah much like grand theft auto yeah you
got the most points for running over
children
and old no old people were the biggest
oh they were they okay yeah old people
were the biggest scorer they had like a
euthanasia day where they'd put all the
people out in the road and you're
supposed to run them over
it's it's and it was kind of funny you
know
[ __ ] it's a it's a dark comedy for
sure
yeah they were kind of like playing on
um soy green
and uh some of the other
post-apocalyptic movies that come before
it
it kind of kind of reminded me of
remember that one
uh that had lee majors in it i think it
was called uh
the final the the la the final chase or
was it the last
chase oh yeah yeah i think that was
called the last chase the last change i
think that was on mystery science
theater actually yeah
like during their uh local when they
were still on a local gym yeah the us
is like a third world totalitarian
country there's no
gasoline or at least they're rationing
it out people couldn't have it
and lee majors takes his race car and
tries to escape
yeah yeah to the free zone and i think
is what they called it and they
resurrect burgess meredith it's like one
of the last fighter pilots and they sent
him
out to go intercept the car yeah that's
pretty cool
that was under users and [ __ ] that was
on a very very early episode of uh
of mystery science theater the ktma
years yeah
yeah i liked that movie when i was a kid
that was actually a pretty good movie
for them actually
yeah uh but yeah so there were like so
many dystopian
movies in the 70s i feel like and uh
yeah this is definitely up there
this is almost kind of like like i said
it's almost like a black comedy
in the way that like the running man is
yeah
um this is kind of like the same sort of
vibe if anything this is even more
ridiculous
yeah um you know oh you're putting on
the hat and the wig
i'm dressed like boss scott now okay
yeah okay
stop distracting me all right well oh
okay no i'm just doing my thing
i'm not distracted stop distracting me
by doing the topic that we're actually
talking no i'm just doing what i'm doing
what do you do just let it roll well
because you're distracting by doing your
little shenanigans
like over there because i'm like what
the hell are you even doing now i'm
gonna put that [ __ ] back
you're gonna put it backwards now i
don't even know who that is now anymore
i'm carrot yeah okay
but yeah so uh so as i said this movie
was actually
roger corman wanted to make uh you know
kind of a dystopian
sports type movie because i guess like
1975 was also the year that rollerball
came out
which was kind of like a similar thing
but it was more like a bigger budget
like studio thing and you know how much
roger corman loved to be like hey
they're going to make a big budget that
we're going to rip that
ball that's another one yeah yeah so
it's kind of like his answer to that
even though it's not
i haven't seen rollerball since i was a
kid so i barely remember him
like this in the running man but it's
yeah it's a similar kind of thing where
in you know in a dystopian future of
2000
um you know people are so jaded that the
biggest sporting event
is a transcontinental race uh where you
just go around running people over and
everybody cheers
uh so you know life is cheap yadda yadda
i said i was
bon scott i actually met brian johnson
second singer
but go ahead yeah okay well i i wouldn't
have known the difference so you know
somebody out there going no but that's
brian john well you know because you're
always going to get something
well actually well actually yeah yeah
yeah so in this movie it's interesting
because i saw this movie
when i was a kid probably like i saw it
on cable a couple of times
and i remembered all the racing [ __ ] but
i didn't remember that this actually
like sort of has a plot
kind of um i didn't remember all the
other [ __ ] that went on in it they had a
deeper message at the end
it did yeah yeah so uh
remember back when there was a world
crash of 1979
which is what uh happened in this movie
back the world crashed in 1979
everything went to [ __ ] and um like you
said this
it's almost kind of like i don't know if
they were saying that it was like a
world government type of thing because
they were kind of talking about like
the us it was kind of like it's based on
some [ __ ]
the writings of the united nations at
that time
what would happen if there was a
worldwide economic collapse could the
world's governments get together and
could the u.n
run a a it's globalism that basically
what they're talking about could
could the united nations run uh the
the economy from there could it govern
you know what i mean collapse
states from there you know and
that kind of those kind of writings were
where like people were reading them and
and
you know freaking them out you know alex
jones style they're like oh man the
[ __ ] you know
the globalist takeover and that's what
they're talking about
well yeah it was very much in the
zeitgeist i mean this is actually based
on a short story
uh called the racer by ib
who actually he wrote a lot of like 50
sci-fi and 60 sci-fi i feel like because
i know i've seen that name before
because how can you forget a name like
ib
milky or yeah i'm just saying but the
the movie did address
issues that like i said oh aj would be
talking about because if you have a
and the movie shows it if you have a one
world government
it really couldn't be a democracy
because you can't get people into one
country to [ __ ] agree on anything
through a democratic problem
how you gonna get all these nations to
agree on anything so it would have to be
kind of totalitarian
and it would have to be like
based in non-consumption they even had
even the rebels who were trying to fight
the damn one world government we're
fighting it through what they call it
inactive resistance passive resistance
which that is resisting by not doing
anything that's not resistance
so the whole thing is kind of funny it's
poking fun
at a dystopian future
i will say though that i don't know that
i don't think that it was like a whole
global government because at some points
they made jokes about how france was
ruining everything
like the french were [ __ ] well i
think they were in the union or coming
out of the union remember they said they
they said on several occasions that the
united states
was was ruled from abroad or at least
that the president had
homes somewhere else in lots of other
countries
right is i guess would like the
implications yeah i understood it as
what they were talking about as a 70s
era
un-based global government is what
i thought they were talking about it all
seems to be there
what they're talking about yeah so
basically you have
i guess what they're doing in true bread
and circus's form
is they're they're trying to get
everybody to like stop complaining or
whatever
by doing this yearly race it's only
yearly right it's annual and it's just
called the transcontinental road race
and like we said there's um you know
it's i don't know they don't really go
much into the previous ones other than
you know saying some [ __ ] about some of
the drivers and whatnot a lot of absurd
[ __ ] too because that
frankenstein won the one of the only
races and he won it twice
and they worded it in a funny way what'd
they call it yeah i can't remember
exactly what they were
two-time winner of a [ __ ] uh of the
first
annual or the first year something or
other race or
and they're like wait a minute hold on
that's one race and you he won it twice
and there there's a lot of
comedy like that in there it was because
i said that's almost like a chuck norris
joke before there was a chuck norris
[ __ ] like that's how badass he is the
shit's [ __ ]
absurd and if you pay attention to the
dialogue it's even more absurd because
there's a bunch of nonsensical [ __ ]
well that's what i mean it's like a
satire it's really interesting because i
think from what i could determine from
everything that i write about this movie
was that when roger corman was first
envisioning it and when he was like you
know doing trying to do the adaptation
of the short story
he wanted to make it kind of more
serious and gritty um but then when he
had like the the screenwriter was
he had like a bunch of comedy so he made
it like a satire
and roger corman was kind of like i
don't know if i like that and he took a
lot of the funny [ __ ] out
but a lot of the funny [ __ ] is still in
there so it's still
very clearly like a black comedy um
but it yeah it is a little tonally weird
but i kind of feel like overarchingly
it's still like a ridiculous comedy
because it's every
every bit of it is like ridiculous i
think you called it though the tone was
very much
like running man with arnold
schwarzenegger well yeah i'm pretty sure
that like
a lower budget yeah i'm pretty sure that
i mean stephen king's running man this
story was kind of more serious than the
movie turned out to be
but i'm assuming that when they made the
movie they were kind of thinking of the
same tone as
death race 2000 i kind of feel like
because i mean a lot of people have seen
death race 2000 it's a big cult
classic so probably rollerball too
like yeah so i kind of feel like that's
where they were getting the idea from
yeah so we're starting in the year 2000
obviously
and uh we have four sets of racers so i
guess every time you have
you have a racer and then they have a
navigator and so like the navigator is
always like switched out yeah well
that's
that's in real life too in rally yeah
it's just they're rally cars basically
so it's that kind of thing and like
every single one of them like you said
has a theme you have frankenstein who's
the main character and he's played by
david carradine
and his shtick which you kind of find
out later on is
[ __ ] it's just dick uh is he has
that black
he must have been like [ __ ] baking
when they were filming like a drummer
outfit
kinda and he should yeah and it's just
kind of like this really tight like
black almost like an s m looking thing
and his big thing is that he had to have
like he was in all these horrible wrecks
and had all his limbs replaced and all
this other kind of [ __ ] like immortal he
couldn't die
yeah every part on him was was replaced
yeah it's like i lost this side
in this race and i lost this eye and
this race it's like even though he still
has
there's very little original him left
and i think they were getting that from
darth vader yeah
even though like i said it wasn't true
because at some point later on he kind
of implied that he was just like a
creation
uh that that was like part of the shtick
like i said so he hadn't actually lost
all his
both his legs and his arms and
everything like he's racing in a
corvette that's been [ __ ]
mocked up to look like a dragon or a
lizard or something yeah what is that
i guess it was supposed to be a dragon i
think it's supposed to be a dragon and
then everybody else is in
vw bugs if it looks like when they were
doing when they were catching air
wheelbase and everything looked like a
vw bug kit and they looked like a damn
belly pan on the bottom so you know
that's that's the frame of a vw
just a [ __ ] single pan and they were
kind of cool looking little
rally cars you know they kind of mocked
up to look like
little triumphs and [ __ ] you know little
tr7s or something
but they were they were more simple than
that one of them was like a nazi one
that was she cracked me up the most
because her her car was called the buzz
bomb right
and uh her name was um what was her
[ __ ] name matilda the han
matilda and she's kind of like
she had a helmet with a [ __ ] swastika
yeah
and she had the [ __ ] herm in the
german herman the german was her
navigator
that's right he's kind of like he's kind
of like a [ __ ] beta
and uh then you had calamity jane with a
cowboy motif and she's kind of like this
[ __ ]
that was mary that was mary warren yeah
it's kind of like this sexually
dominated
dominating kind of [ __ ] sex [ __ ]
pot woman who's constantly trying to
seduce men and [ __ ] bring him under
control and [ __ ]
trying to cowgirl the [ __ ] out of him i
guess and then the dude from
uh the dude from uh the [ __ ] karate
kid
was he didn't last too long he was he
was nero the hero
yeah and uh his navigator's name was
cleopatra right yeah
they were the first ones to get rubbed
out i think yeah i think they lasted
about five minutes
she was all boobalicious and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] her top
[ __ ] the cleavage was this far and
went all the way down to her belly
button
yeah and so yeah she so yeah some of the
shots when they were like talking to you
that was like funny as well yeah and
then another one of the cars was uh
uh it was sylvester stallone and his
second girlfriend and they were dressed
like [ __ ] 1920s
rolling roaring 20s gangsters we caught
himself [ __ ] uh he was a machine gun
joe
machine gun joe the turbo and he was
kind of like the main antagonist
because he was like the main rival he
was like this because frankenstein was
like
the biggest driver and like the most
famous and machine gun was like second
place
yeah um and i love that sylvester
stallone in this movie
they just let him be because he doesn't
really get to be a bad guy all that much
and he was just a complete and utter
[ __ ] rage monster in this thing yeah
girl sits outside was he punch her pow
pow yeah there's a lot of girl punching
yeah she kept punching his girlfriend in
the face
and she's just a bimbo you know she just
know what it she had her helmet was all
covered with white fur
yeah yeah i [ __ ] love that the crowd
booed him and everything he pulled out
of thompson submachine gun
shooting at the [ __ ] crowd out in the
bleachers yeah there's a lot of good
good moments yeah he was like super
funny in this and like i said it's
really good because they just let him
kind of rampage all over this and just
like
yeah he's just punching people and
[ __ ] yeah acting crazy running people
over
running people over and acting [ __ ]
crazy and whatnot yeah so he's kind of
like you know the main guy that wants to
beat frankenstein because he really
hates frankenstein's guts
uh and you know every single scene he's
just sitting there going fine man [ __ ]
that guy
so it's all that kind of [ __ ] now you
have all so you have the race going on
and like we mentioned earlier
you not only have to get to because
they're going from like the east coast
to the west coast so you not only have
to have to get to new los angeles
first before everybody else but you also
have to
uh rack up the most amount of points by
the way and how you get uh
along the way and how you get points is
by running over
pedestrians so what they i think they
bring up at some point that because this
race is annual and it's a big deal and
everybody knows what it is
um most people stay off the roads
but uh i guess there are some for
whatever reason
like some people kind of want to go
because like we said earlier like the
hospitals have
euthanasia day where they wheel all the
old folks like out into the street like
to let them get run over
um some people maybe they forget about
it there was one guy that was dressed
like a bullfighter that was like
treasure
out there trying to find the car yeah
there's that kind of [ __ ] it's just just
absurd yeah it's ridiculous you're like
this dude get out of it
nothing evidently he's just gonna go
bullfight the cars there's a whole scene
that both him bullfighting this car well
because you know there would be at least
one dude that would do that if this
really happened
i was thinking that i was like you know
it seems ridiculous but if that really
came to pass like some kind of purge
situation
uh you know there'd be at least one
person doing that probably more than one
because you know how humans are
yeah well according to the
revolutionaries there wasn't much
purpose for life
in the in this in this world yeah like
they didn't do much anything
so the the the country was just run by a
bunch of oligarchs too they mentioned
that oligarchs were running
but running a bunch of monopolies was
part of it yeah so there was
you know so the people really didn't do
much they kind of had a free and easy
life
sitting around waiting waiting to be
told when to die basically
yeah so is it because when they wheel
the old people out like every like the
old people just like okay this is that's
how it goes you know what i mean yeah
um you know they and the old people
don't actually get run over though
because
frankenstein goes around and runs over a
bunch of the nurses instead which is
hilarious because
all you you just see the car like go
behind the the shrubbery and then all of
a sudden these nurses start flying
everywhere and some of these locations
were like where the hell
is this some of it's map paintings but
there some of this stuff is real
yeah the first place it the first part
where um
you know where they're starting the race
and it's supposed to look futuristic
that's a very obvious map painting
yeah but i think most of the other [ __ ]
looked like it was shot in a real
location
yeah it wasn't it wasn't it was a
dystopia but
there wasn't any poverty like it didn't
show poverty
it's just that life had no purpose yeah
according to what they were saying it
kind of like a star trek type situation
but there's no reason to live there they
didn't do anything
that's what that's what it seemed i
guess just so you could say kind of like
logan's run
yeah i guess so they were kind of
charming they were kind of useless
people
useless eaters and yeah and it's like i
guess when you think about the point
system that they have where like the
elderly were like 100 points each
they're trying to get rid of them um
yeah because so yeah it was like uh
going down a scale of like most to least
like useful i guess yeah so like old
people were 100 points
uh children under 12 were 70 points and
they called them toddlers toddlers under
12. toddlers under 12. well i was just
like i guess anything under 12 is
considered a toddler and it's like
because a toddler is not that no like i
said
i know that but i think that was like
kind of the joke because they're like
well if you're under 12 years
old you can't have a job or anything
like that so you might as well be inside
like
i think that's what they're talking
about so i mean so so you're ending up
with like scenes where
you know some of the like the drivers
like they see the like this
family having a picnic ever that doesn't
turn out if it turns out to be like the
resistance or whatever but they think
it's really them
and it's like aim for the baby ain't for
the baby
it's just kind of like it's just so
[ __ ] it's but it's so ridiculous and
there's a lot of
i was going to say there's a lot of gore
in it but it's just like ridiculous
looking gore and a lot of it
and it doesn't look real like all the
blood looks like fake paint like so they
like run over people and like smush
their heads and stuff but it's just like
not
it doesn't look anything like realistic
so it's just like funny and over the top
but so so you have all that going on but
then you also have frankenstein
and his navigator who was a new
navigator because i guess
don't they mention at some point that
like all his navigators have died
like during the race somehow i don't
know if they're implying that he killed
them or if they die during the course of
the race or whatever
but so he has a new navigator uh this
hot chick named
annie and as the story goes on spoiler
alert you find out that
she is actually part of the resistance
and part of their plan
was they were going to they were going
to take
frankenstein hostage and then they were
going to make the government
stop the race like uh abolish the race
because they thought that he would be
like a good bargaining chip because he
was like this big
national hero or whatever yeah he also
had a funny thing to mention though
he also had a fan club of a bunch of hot
goth girls basically dressed all in
black yeah they have black shirts with
like an f
on them yeah that were willing to
[ __ ] jump out in front of the car and
kill themselves so he'd get more points
that's looking cool fun fact that girl
that girl that came to him and like
and talked about that like from the fan
club i think that that was maybe
the screenwriter's sister okay or the
director's sister
all right because was it paul partel's
sister it might have been
but yeah it was one of the it was one of
those two guys sister that like put in
the movie
but yeah she came there and she was like
the big fan and we're big fans of yours
and she's like i wanted to meet you so
it would have meaning and he's like so
what would have meaning i was like she's
gonna jump in front of his [ __ ] car
at some point made you think that she
wanted to screw him but no she wanted to
[ __ ] give her life for him so she
would have so
he could get more points and win the
race that was another thing too is that
i guess if you were the navigator
yeah even if you were the new navigator
you were just expected to like [ __ ] the
driver
yeah because they would every time like
at the end of every leg of the race
they would go to like a um you know like
a love move like a love motel or it was
just kind of like where they would stay
for a day or two
and they'd all they'd all be naked on
the thing and they'd all be getting
massages
and then you'd go to the it's like a pit
stop yeah you go to the room with like
your navigator
and you're just that was just like
expected you know what i mean which i
thought was kind of funny well they were
just trying to say that in the future it
was real [ __ ] kind of hedonistic
yeah you know what sex wasn't a big deal
and i kind of feel like it's funny too
because you could clearly tell like the
place where they were all getting
uh massages that looked like a mall
from like the seventies walled the dab
they just walled the damn storefronts
off but you know
[ __ ] them all and i think that like the
big super futuristic like bedrooms and
stuff with all the red
doors i did they were either empty
stores or it was like a high school gym
or something
like one of them one of them where he
was taking his clothes off and [ __ ] they
were doing the dance that was a store
yeah yeah with first it was like yeah it
was like a mall that they were just like
hey can we clear all the [ __ ] out of the
store and like film our movie in there
well like i said roger corman he's like
very very budget-minded
but yeah so so all along like while
they're doing the race
um you have the drivers kind of trying
to kill each other
they don't really have a route that they
take which is why they have navigators
they can split up and you can take
whatever route you want yeah um so some
of them are like hey i heard there was
like an old folks home or like a place
where they're like a boy scout camp or
something where a bunch of people would
be running around that they could run
over and get points and stuff
so it's like so they'd all take
different routes but then in this
in the same token like the drivers are
kind of trying to kill each other and
then also the resistance has like kind
of all these plans
and then as it goes on like frankenstein
sort of twigs on to the fact
that annie is working for the resistance
and so is kind of like working at cross
purposes to him
yeah he's kind of sick of this and he
doesn't really believe in it you find
out later yeah
he kind of joins the resistance in the
way yeah and um
i don't know if you want to spoil the
end or whatever well i kind of feel like
everyone's seen death race 2000 or
and the thing about it too is that it
was remade in 2008
with jason statham although i don't know
if they were
they when they said that it was like
supposed to be like a remake but i think
it was supposed to be a prequel
because you know in the at the end of
this movie
the race gets abolished right um
but in the you know in the movie they're
still
doing it and frankenstein is still a
character and blah blah
but it's kind of like i kind of feel
like i haven't seen the remake
but from what i could determine from the
wikipedia plot synopsis
i think they took out that whole thing
about
running over pedestrians and getting
points for it yeah
um and also it's not funny like it was
like a serious like dystopian
and i think they really missed a trick
there i think they could have made it
like really funny
well like i said you can do it kind of
funny like the purge
that's kind of like you know black humor
type [ __ ]
yeah running up running over the
civilians was that was the best
one of the best parts well they were
just trying to show you that the human
life had no meaning really right
at you know at this point in time and
like i said the tone of it is just so
over the top ridiculous and i mean they
have everybody in their like horrifying
70s fashions
they have like the dude that's doing all
the commentary
it's just like so over the top with like
the [ __ ] necker chief and all that
kind of [ __ ] yeah
like talking about all the [ __ ] that
happens they have and that other woman
they have in her
her last name is pander right grace
pander and she um
she's kind of one of those like oh i
love everybody is my friend my dear
friend we're gonna interview this person
and that person
and we're gonna do this and they're
giving prizes to like the widow of the
first dude that got run over in the race
and [ __ ] like that
it seems ridiculous to us but in a way
that
stuff like this happened in rome with
the gladiatorial fights all the time it
was just they
they accepted it like for instance if uh
if uh if a section of the of the
audience got unruly sometimes if an
emperor or somebody who real high
ranking who if he was
proceeding over the games would go like
that section right there [ __ ] them throw
them in there
and they would throw a whole section of
people into the arena
to be killed
you know what i mean it'd be the same
kind of mentality if if you're gonna go
out and watch
death race and be a part of death race
you getting run over
hey that that's part of the game yeah so
you know you're the one out there
watching it
i mean you know machine gun whatever his
name was a
huge machine gun machine gun joe was
shooting into the audience of people who
boo
right there in his name yeah i mean you
know right and also he backed over his
own pit crew
right to get points yeah well because
and another thing that frankenstein did
too and i thought this was another funny
uh bit
was that he kind of he dropped his glove
and then he circled back around so he
could specifically like run over one of
the race officials
and then like bishop and then like yeah
and then like all the other race we were
like wait does that count
and then like somebody came and said
yeah it does count
and i said okay well then from that
point forward you'd think that the
drivers would just go around like
running over all the race officials and
running over parts of the crowd and
stuff like that because you get all kind
of points right
we got the points not because he was a
race official just because he was bishop
yeah remember he was like a really he
was a religious yeah he was like
overseeing the i guess overseeing it but
that's what they gave the points for
from what i remember because they didn't
do it again
yeah like i said and it's i was watching
another review of it earlier and the guy
was like you'd think because
at one point machine gun joe like i said
backs over two of his own pit crew
to get the points and i was like you
think that more people would do that
you know what i mean like because it
seems like easy points they're just
standing right there
you don't get many points for men though
they said um
the men you didn't get much points women
you i think you only got 10 points per
um mostly the thing was old people and
children yeah uh was what gave you the
most points
you know what i mean i maybe because
like i said
because they were implying that oh they
were more useless
to the society and also maybe because um
they didn't come out to the race or they
wouldn't have a reason to be out in the
road so much so it was like rarer maybe
i think it was just because it was they
were more vulnerable yeah so there was a
you got more points because it was more
humorous yeah you know what i mean
because it was
because it just reminded me it's funny
because i mean spirited
yeah i even think before i even saw this
movie um we used to make jokes a lot
like when we were kids
uh you know my dad would be driving and
like somebody'd be crossing the street
and be really slow and be like 20 points
20 points you know what i mean so i
i kind of feel like a lot of people have
done that um so like i said that's why
so many people like grand theft auto
because it's kind of the same sort of
thing
you can do it without feeling bad but um
but yeah so
so i definitely had a framework for that
kind of joke
but as i said it's just so over the top
and ridiculous that it's like you can't
really take it seriously yeah it has
like some [ __ ] to say it's like much
deeper than i remembered it being
yeah and i had forgotten the whole uh
you know the people the resistance angle
and like his navigator being part of the
resistance and
uh you know her being the granddaughter
of thomasina that
uh thomasina payne which i thought was
really funny uh he was kind of like this
old
crotchety old lady who was like the head
of the resort they don't get it so
thomas payne was a revolutionary yeah
american revolutionary so yeah so it was
all that and there's like some funny
jokes in there about
uh the french because sometimes like
when [ __ ] would happen
like when matilda the hun like goes over
um
a cliff in a very wily coyote moment
um she's just kind of like goes off the
road and goes off a cliff
and uh they try to make it seem like
even though she died they made it seem
like she scored a whole bunch of points
so it's
they were kind of making a commentary
too about how like the media like
distorted everything
you know what i mean because some [ __ ]
would like a car would blow up and then
they'd
like change the story then they'd say
like um at one point
the resistance had a little plane and
they were trying to kill frankenstein
and uh what they were saying like when
something happened to the car they said
it was the french air force
you know what i mean so uh so they're
making all these jokes about the french
like [ __ ] up everything which i
thought was really funny that was like
kind of a running joke throughout
but yeah so if you like these kind of
ridiculous
um 70s dystopian type of movies like i
said this one is much
funnier and like much more self-aware
than
somebody it's not serious at all even
though i kind of feel like roger corman
wanted it to be serious
and he took a lot of jokes out at least
according to the screenwriter
but most of it is just still [ __ ]
funny yeah you know what i'm saying so
oh interestingly we watched this on
toby it's free on there but weirdly and
i've never seen this happen before
there's a lot of nudity in this and it
was all like pixelated out
yeah and i don't think and and i've
watched
tons of movies on tubey and they as far
as i know they never cut any nudity out
it was just the edit that they had that
they've copied
so i kind of feel like maybe i was like
did you get a japanese laserdisc print
or something like that
maybe there's a pg-13 um although all
the swearing was
in there and there's a lot of swearing
and a lot of blood like
there's by accident that's what i'm
saying because i i was like yeah i've
watched lots of movies on tubing and
they never take anything out they don't
cut it they put commercials in there
sometimes but they don't cut it
there must be an uh a non-nude version
and they accidentally put that up
maybe so but like i said all the it's
not the pg-13 version because all the
swearing and the gore is still in there
it was only just the boobies and bush
that they pixelated out which i thought
was very odd
but yeah so i don't know what's the deal
toby somebody let me know
but yeah so if you watched it on to be
keep that in mind you won't be able to
see uh
any boobies yeah you can get it for like
three bucks on
amazon prime yeah you can just run it on
there and i'm sure you can find it
someplace else too i'm just sounding
like arnold schwarzenegger's a running
man
kind of yeah older
less of a budget yeah yeah super super
cheap
but like also kind of funny a lot of
funny ridiculous
but that same premise basically yeah but
same premise so yeah that'll do it for
this
uh movie retrospective we will see you
guys on the next one
bye